et merci de votre présence et surtout
merci aux collègues qui ont réussi à à
rester parce que comme je le disais tout
à l'heure un grand nombre d'entre eux
ont été un peu perturbés par le contexte
agricole qui
soitfin les empêcher de rentrer chez eux
ou les appeler à devoir revenir de
manière un peu
précipitée dans leur département mais
voilà comme le disait madame rouget
comme cette audition est capté ils
pourront profiter de vos interventions
de manière différée ou en direct depuis
chez eux puisqueeffectivement donc cette
matinée nous l'avions prévu de longue
date alors elle ne va pas ouvrir les
travaux de la délégation puisqu'on a
déjà commencé à travailler depuis la
reprise et la réinstallation du Sénat au
mois au mois d'octobre mais nous
souhaitions la faire puisquil y a déjà 6
ans en fait dans un format différent
nousous étions interrogés sur qu'est-ce
que la prospective alors comme les
membres de la délégation ont été
fortement renouvelé au cours des six
dernières années c'était bien de refaire
ce travail et ce que je trouve la enfin
nous sommes particulièrement chanceux
puisquen fait aujourd'hui nous allons à
la fois pouvoir croiser un peu le regard
théorique porté par futurible et par
François de Jouvenel et des regards
beaucoup plus pratiques avec Olivier
ouv Nagel qui est directeur de
l'économie de RTE dont on connaît les
prospective de long terme le scénario
2050 et ensuite dans le domaine de
l'armée avec le commandant Jean-Baptiste
Colas qui est actuellement directeur au
cabinet du du DGA alors ce que je vais
vous demander en fait c'est de de de
nous dire euh comment déjà vous concevez
la prospective euh quels sont les les
outils que vous utiliser et alors en
vous disant aussi que cette année la
délégation a choisi de conduire ses
travaux au thème autour du thème de l'
de l'intelligence artificiel et donc de
nous faire si c'est possible une petite
ouverture enfin pour nous dire en tout
cas si c'est si ce nouvel outil change
pour vous vos manières de faire de la
prospective je vous cède la parole je
sais pas qui souhaite commencer
peut-être monsieur de
Jouvenel merci beaucoup pour votre
invitation à à intervenir aujourd'hui
sur sur la prospective donc mon mon
objectif ça va effectivement de manière
relativement brève de pouvoir présenter
quels sont les principes de la
prospective et puis peut-être aussi de
donner quelques éclairages sur le
paysage de la prospective aujourd'hui de
manière relativement large avant de
donner la parole à mes deux collègues
qui rentreront effectivement dans des
présentation d'exemples plus précis et
par ailleurs me semble-t-il tout à fait
complémentaire sur le pour vous dire en
quelques mots d'où je parle également
donc je suis le directeur de futurib
futurib c'est un centre indépendant de
de réflexion et d'études prospectives
qui existe depuis les années 1960 donc
qui a accompagné le développement des
démarches de prospective depuis lors et
qui donc on bénéficie d' d'un regard
relativement voilà transversal et
historique sur ces sur le le
développement de la prospective ses
méthodes ces outils ces champs
d'application on ne reste pas uniquement
dans la théorie de la prospective
puisqueon a aussi toute des champs
d'application pratique on accompagne un
certain nombre de démarches de
prospective on produit des travaux de
prospective et donc on a les mains dans
le cambouille si je puis dire voilà donc
on essaie d'allier une partie
effectivement de réflexion sur les
principes et sur les méthodes avec la
conduite opérationnelle d'un certain
nombre de démarches sur la prospective
de manière générale depuis ses origines
elle a évidemment évolué dans ses formes
ces principes eux restent relativement
inchangés même si le contexte dans
lequel elle se situe les objets dont
elle se saisit eux ont évidemment évolué
relativement de manière relativement
importante sur les
principes la définition qui me semble la
plus claire c'est celle affichée ici de
Michel Godet qui dit de de quoi
s'agit-il quand on fait de la
prospective il s'agit d'éclairer
l'action présente à la lumière des
futurs possibles et souhaitables c'est
important tout est un peu important dans
cette dans cette définition l'objectif
vous le voyez c'est pas juste d'être
dans le la futurologie c'est-à-dire
d'être en capacité éventuellement de
prédire ce qui pourrait se passer mais
c'est bien d'éclairer l'action présente
de ce point de vue-l d'ailleurs ça me
semble tout à fait important que la
prospective soit représentée au Sénat
puisque un des objectifs nobles si je
puis dire de la prospective c'est
justement aussi de pouvoir servir à
éclairer la décision publique il s'agit
pas de dicter évidemment la décision
publique mais bien de l'éclairer en
portant un regard sur les enjeux de
moyen et de long terme quand on dit
porter un regard sur les enjeux de moyen
et de long terme c'est d'abord un effort
tout simplement c'est-à-dire prendre le
temps de se préoccupé de ces enjeux de
moyen et de long terme alors que l'on
sait bien que dans toutes vos activités
dans toutes nos activités on est très
souvent contraint justement par les
urgences du temps présent donc je dirais
de manière assez simple d'ailleurs que
faire de la prospective c'est d'abord
essayer de sanctuariser en quelque sorte
un peu de temps et un peu de moyen dédié
à cette réflexion sur le moyen et le
long
terme on prend souvent la métaphore du
du navigateur pour expliquer un petit
peu ce qu'est la prospective le
navigateur il doit prendre un certain
nombre de décisions pour emmener son
embarcation et il a à sa disposition
donc deux instruments il a un instrument
qui est la vigie qui lui permet d'aller
observer ce qui se passe dans son
environnement proche d'abord mais aussi
dans son environnement plus éloigné
d'aller regarder ce qui se passe à
l'horizon et de se poser un certain
nombre de questions sur la façon dont ce
qu' le repèent dans la situation
actuelle peut prendre comme forme pour
demain est-ce que le nuage gros comme le
point va se transformer en tempête ou
finalement disparaître à l'horizon le
prospectiviste est dans cette positionl
on essayer de repérer un certain nombre
d'évolutions à travers les la bonne
compréhension que l'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui de la situation présente et
puis un regard porté autant que possible
sur l'avenir et d'essayer
d'interpréter les signes que l'on peut
voir et qui nous semblent révélateurs ou
annonciateurs de transformations
importantes pour demain pour construire
un certain nombre de raisonnement sur ce
qu' pourrait se passer et donc la
prospective travaille beaucoup à travers
des scénarios les scénarios ce sont des
histoires de futur possible qui cherche
à encadrer la diversité des situations
auxquelles on pourrait se confronter
l'objectif derrière cela c'est d'essayer
de se préparer le mieux possible à
l'avenir donc la prospective c'est
porter un regard sur le sur la venir
explorer les futurs possibles pour
pouvoir nous aider à se préparer à ce
qu'on pense qu'il pourrait advenir
euh j'ai mis quelques éléments ici sur
le sur le sur l'histoire pas pour
refaire un long un long historique de la
prospective mais pour rappeler que cet
effort d'anticipation il est pas neuf il
a toujours existé par contre sa
professionnalisation
l'institutionnalisation des pratique de
prospective elle date grosso modo des
années 30 et surtout des années d'après
ce Seconde Guerre mondiale dans lesquels
les pouvoirs publics d'abord ont
ressenti le besoin de disposer d'une
bonne compréhension des grandes
transformation en cours dans les
domaines technologiques dans les
domaines de société pour pouvoir
justement permettre d'orienter
d'éclairer les décisions public qui
était prise c'est premières premiers
travaux de prospective ont été
développés sous Roosevelt au moment où
l'État fédéral américain s'investissait
justement dans des dans des domaines
dans lesquels il était relativement
relativement
absent aujourd'hui si on en vient au
présent il y a un certain nombre de
transformations évidemment importantes
dans le paysage de la prospective ces
transformations importantes dans le
paysage à la prospective elles sont
liées aux transformations du contexte
dans lequel nous vivons donc des sujets
dont nous nous saisissons j'en ai mis
ici j'ai mis ici quelques points qui me
paraissent importants qui sont pas
exhaustifs mais qui me paraissent utile
de de mentionner premier point c'est le
fait qu'aujourd'hui les travaux de
prospectif sont très fortement tirés par
les problématiques dites de transition
donc très fortement tiré évidemment par
la prégnance des enjeux environnementaux
dégradation climatique de la
biodiversité et cetera qui finalement
font que les discours sur le futur n'ont
sans doute jamais été aussi présents
aujourd'hui que euh que par le par le
passé on dit souvent qu'on manque de
prospective en réalité il y a
aujourd'hui un grand nombre de travaux
de réflexion sur le futur qui sont
notamment beaucoup tiré par ces par la
prise de conscience de ces de ces
transformations écologiques sur ces
transformations environnementales le
paradoxe auquel on est confronté c'est
que à la fois elle nous amène un certain
nombre de d'évolutions irréversibles
donc en quelque sorte prévisible on pas
inverser la courbe des températures
demain matin et en même temps ces
irréversibilité entraîne aussi
l'augmentation du nombre de phénomènes
imprévisibles et donc une
imprévisibilité globale qui s'accroit ce
qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut dire que
aujourd'hui dans les travaux de
prospective on doit tenir un peu deux
cordes à la fois essayer d'anticiper au
mieux ce que ce sur quoi on peut avoir
un certain nombre de certitudes et puis
en même temps se préparer à des
situations de crise et de surprise de
plus en plus nombreuses et les deux
exemples qu'on aura tout à l'heure je
pense permettront aussi de d'illustrer
assez bien justement la diversité de de
ce type de
pratique la deuxième chose importante
c'est les transformations finalement
géopolitiques disons qui font que on est
rentré dans une période dans laquelle
disons le modèle du
libéralisme à la fois démocratique et
économique qui apparaissait entre les
années 1990 et 2020 comme étant un peu
le l'horizon un peu unique de de
l'histoire a disparu a un peu volé en
éclat on a aujourd'hui des tensions
géopolitiques relativement fortes
l'affirmation de modèles assez
différents l'idée aussi même au niveau
international que les valeurs sur
lesquelles on a bâti l'ordre après 45 ne
sont plus forcément totalement partagé
et ça ça s'accompagne aussi par
finalement de développement au niveau
international d'un paysage de la
prospective qui se transforme
relativement fortement qui n'est plus
uniquement un paysage de prospective
marqué par les pays occidentaux mais
avec l'émergence de travaux de
prospective avec une dimension parfois
culturelle relativement forte une
affirmation aussi par exemple qu'il faut
décoloniser le futur que l'on peut
retrouver aussi dans des travaux dans
différentes dans différentes régions du
monde ça me paraît être un point
important parce que la prospective est
aussi aujourd'hui un moyen de donner la
parole à des minorité euh qui euh et à
des à des à des personnes marginalisées
en leur demandant de se en les amenant à
se réapproprier finalement le
futur troisième point important les j'ai
mis des vrais entre guillemets travau de
prospective scientifique et
technologique sont peu nombreux vous
avez parlé d'intelligence
artificielle il y a toute une économie
de la promesse comme vous le savez
autour des des nouvelles technologies
donc on est envahi de discours sur
l'avenir des nouvelles technologies en
revanche des travaux rigoureux et donc
critiques sur les avancées de ces
technologies sont relativement peu
nombreux pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que les le rythme des découvertes
finalement est assez rapide et donc nous
amène à être continuellement surpris
donc il y a une difficulté je dirais
presque ontologique essayer d'anticiper
les formes que pourrai prendre ces
technologies donc il y a aussi tout un
pan qui sur lequel on doit
nécessairement être en découverte un peu
permanente et puis finalement ces
travaux de prospectif demandent aussi
des compétences et qu'ils ne sont pas
nécessairement partout partagés et donc
benah il faut effectivement que les
différentes instantces qui sont en
capacité effectivement de piloter ou de
commanditer ce type de travaux puissent
s'en
saisir de derniers point rapide j'ai mis
aussi un point sur les chemins étroits
mais variés de la prospective comme
réflexion collective pour nourrir des
processus de décision pardon pour cette
formulation peut-être un petit peu
complexe ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que dans les grandes évolutions
aussi que l'on a et qu'on a pu voir dans
la prospective on a eu une prospective
pendant très longtemps qui qui visait
surtout à permettre d'éclairer les
décideurs donc les décideurs à la fois
au niveau public donc en France par
exemple c'était la prospective a éé
portée par le commissaire général du
Plan par la data et cetera euh et puis
des décideurs privés la prospective s
aussi beaucoup développé dans les
grandes entreprises notamment les
grandes entreprises industrielles dans
le domaine de l'énergie particulièrement
bon euh aujourd'hui la prospective à
partir du moment où elle vise à éclairer
justement des prises de décision elle
doit aussi s'adapter au aux évolutions
des modalités de prise de décision or on
est dans un monde dans lesquel il y a
aussi des phénomènes
d'individualisation dans lesquels les le
rapport aux institutions a changé et
donc dans lesquel la prospective si elle
veut effectivement permettre
d'accompagner des prises de décisions
doit pouvoir travailler dans euh une
avec des formes variées qui permettent
finalement des moments de délibération
extrêmement réguli au fur et à mesure
que les démarches en entreprise et donc
pas uniquement finalement être cantonné
dans des cellules qui sont placées à
côté du prince pour aller
vite le dernier point pour qui permettra
de de de terminer c'est le fait que les
les outils de prospective eux aussi
évidemment évolue en fait il y a jamais
eu véritablement d'outil spécifique de
la prospective il y a pas de boîte
magique de la prospective il y a pas un
logiciel dans lequel on permet de on
rentre les données d'aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir avoir les scénarios du futur on
y reviendra sans doute avec RTE tout à
l'heure en revanche les travaux de
prospectif s'appuient sur des outils
existants ça peut être les outils de la
modélisation qui eu même se transforme
ça peut être des outils d'autres
disciplines donc la prospective en
quelque sorte pille tout ce qu'elle peut
piller pour pouvoir essayer de parvenir
et de répondre à ces à ses à ses
ambitions donc de ce point de vue-là
aujourd'hui ce qui se développe en terme
en terme d'approche c'est que au-delà
des rapports qui à mon sens ont toujours
un sens puisque le passage à l'écrit
permet d'obtenir une rigueur
intellectuelle qui gage quand même la
qualité des travaux mais à côté de ça on
a des différents formats et différents
outils qui se développent notamment la
partie jeu pas mal par ex au ministère
des armées aussi vous en reparlerai sans
doute le l'approche aussi donc par la
alors on a à la fois des travaux de
prospective sur l'intelligence
artificielle et puis on peut tout à fait
utiliser aussi des dispositifs
d'intelligence artificielle dans des
travaux de prospective sans attendre non
plus que l'intelligence artificielle
nous dise exactement ce que sera le
futur peut-être que RTE en reparlera
aussi et puis donc des travaux on
utilise aussi de plus en plus
aujourd'hui des approches du design
fiction notamment pour travailler plus
qu'auparavant sur les imaginaires du
futur et sur l'incarnation finalement
des différents futurs possibles de telle
sorte que ces futurs puissent être
davantage approprié voilà je vais
m'arrêter là pour pas être trop long et
puis pour permettre justement qu'on
rentre dans le dans le concret comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure avec donc les
exemples de de RTE et de la r team
défense je vous remercie merci bah RTE
puisquil
était sauf si vous avez été prévu
organisé non c'était et ben c'est
parfait non c'est bon je peux commencer
donc
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci pour votre
invitation à à parler un peu de la
démarche prospective de RT je sais pas
si
letit je pour passer les diapositives
bon je vais tenter de vous présenter en
quelques minutes l'approche prospective
de RTE en l'illustrant avec l'exemple
des des scénarios futur énergétique 2050
que nous avons publié il y a quelques
années alors je vais pas chercher à vous
restituer les enseignements de cette
étude mais plutôt
vous expliquer la méthode qu'on a essayé
de poursuivre parce que je crois que
c'est le sujet qui vous intéresse
aujourd'hui alors commencer par vous
rappeler je crois que ça marche pas je
sais pas si ah si c'est bon vous vous
rappelez en quoi rTE est concerné par
une démarche prospective al en fait en
tant que gestionnaire du réseau de
transport d'électricité on a dans nos
mission légale plusieurs objets qui qui
relèvent de la prospective énergétique
et nous devons VT publier régulièrement
des documents de projection sur le
système donc notamment deux documents
qui sont cité dans le code de l'énergie
vous les voyez ici le bilan prévisionnel
bilan prévisionnel plurannuel de
l'équilibre offre demande dont le but
est de fournir des projections sur
l'évolution de la consommation et de la
production d'électricité et d'évaluer
les besoins pour assurer cet équilibre à
tout moment sur un horizon qui va de 5 à
15 15 ans deuxème document qui est cité
dans le code de l'énergie c'est le
schéma décennal de développement du
réseau ou SDDR de son petit nom qui vise
lui à établir une vision sur l'évolution
à court moyen et long terme de
l'infrastructure réseau de RCH
nécessaire pour accompagner les
transitions en cours donc l'objectif de
ces travaux-l c'est avant tout
d'assurer le l'équilibre production
consommation vous savez que sur
l'électricité comme c'est une énergie
qui qui se stock assez peu il y a il y a
il y a un travail important qui est fait
pour assurer cet équilibre en frudement
à tout moment euh donc voilà ces travaux
de prospectiv il visent à alimenter
cette cette missionlà et il vise aussi à
assurer le bon dimensionnement de
l'infrastructure de réseau à long terme
donc c'est pour ça que de longue dates
RTE comme d'autres acteurs du secteur de
l'énergie on a développé une expertise
technique assez développée de euh de de
projection euh sur le système
énergétique parce que
si on anticipe pas si on se projette pas
derrière on a un risque sur le bon
fonctionnement du système électrique
audelà de ces deux objets qui sont cités
dans dans la
loi pas
d'sation
sur la prospec fixée par le code de
l'énergie
oui désolé de vous ramener à un sujet
plus technique peut-être je vous me
dites si je peux oui je peux je peux
poursuivre c'est
bon donc au-delà des des du code de
l'énergie cette cette mission elle est
aussi mentionné explicitement dans notre
contrat de service public dans le
contrat de service public qui liit RTE à
l'État puisune partie ce contrat est
dédié à la mission d'éclairer les choix
énergétiques des pouvoirs publics et des
citoyens et donc voà on est bien dans
dans la mission de prospective qui a été
citée par François de Jouvenel éclairer
les décisions présentes au regard des
des des futurs possibles donc bon ce
cadre estant posé ah je me suis trompé
ce cadre estant posé j'en viens à la
manière dont on a appréhender la
question de la prospective au cours des
dernières années sur le plan du système
électrique alors vous pouvez constater
que dans les documents que j'ai cité
juste avant le la loi nous impose de
faire des projections un horizon de
l'ordre de 5 à 10 ans ou 15 ans à ces
horizons de temps là pour le le secteur
énergétique on est presque plus dans la
prévision que dans la prospective vu les
les délais de de d'évolution des des
infrastructures vu les les les
constantes de temps sur l'évolution des
modes de vie quand on se regarde à 10 15
ans on est en partie sur de la prévision
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que notre
exercice sur les scénarios s'appelle
formellement le bilan prévisionnel et
c'est aussi ça que l'on faisait dans les
années 2000 et 2010 on faisait des
études prévisionnelles sur l'évolution
de la consommation et de la production
d'électricité c'est-à-dire qu'on on
faisait des prévisions dans un contexte
donné à politique publique donné et
c'était sur la base de ça qu'on pouvait
projeter l'évolution sur des échelles de
5 10 15 ans depuis la fin des années
2010 et le début des années année 2020
le contexte a changé et en fait la la
réflexion sur l'évolution du système
énergétique
elle s'est projeté sur des
durées de plus long terme et donc c'est
pour ça qu'à partir de fin 2021 on a euh
progressivement basculé sur des études
plus prospectives alors d'une part parce
qu'à la suite de l'accord de Paris euh
l'objectif climat énergie de la France
il s'est orienté vers la question de la
neutralité carbone en 2050 donc qui
passe par la sortie des énergies
fossiles sur les prochaines décennies et
d'autre part parce que bah comme je
citaé juste avant les dynamique
industrielle et sociétale qui impacte le
secteur énergétique
elle s'étale sur des durées longues de
l'ordre de plusieurs décennies il faut
une douzaine d'années pour construire un
nouveau réacteur nucléaire il faut 7 à
10 ans pour construire un parc éolien en
mer il faut à peu près la même chose
pour plusieurs années en tout cas pour
construire de nouvelles lignes
électriques et toutes ces
infrastructures là elles elles ont des
durées de vie de l'ordre de plusieurs
décennies donc forcément quand on essaie
de penser à l'avenir du secteur
énergétique on est Oblet de se projeter
sur des échelles de temps qui sont plus
longues et ça pose d'autres questions
donc pour répondre à ces différentes
questions on a on a on a poussé plus
loin l'exercice jusqu'à 2050 et 2060 et
et et c'est et c'est à ce moment-là
qu'on est passé vraiment sur une
approche prospective c'est-à-dire que on
a on est parti d'un objectif un objectif
qui est celui de la neutralité carbone
en 2050 on est parti de l'objectif de
sortie des énergies fossiles et sur la
base de de cet objectif on a on a
construit et étudié différentes
trajectoires possiblebl pour l'atteindre
et vous voyez ici je vous ai remis un
petit graphique sur la consommation
d'énergie vous voyez que le défi est est
immense en fait pour le secteur
électrique puisque aujourd'hui même si
on a tendance à penser que
l'électricité est omniprésente que
notamment dans le débat sur l'énergie en
fait n'est que 25 % de notre
consommation d'énergie il y a encore 60
% de notre énergie de notre consommation
d'énergie qui repose sur les les
énergies fossiles le pétrole et le gaz
notamment et donc bah sortir de ces
énergies fossiles ça implique des
transformations très importantes il faut
d'une part baisser la consommation
d'énergie mais il faut aussi remplacer
les énergies fossiles par des énergies
bas carbone comme l'électricité et donc
si la consommation d'énergie va baisser
celle d'électricité elle va augmenter
donc c'est un une vraie le point de
départ de notre étude sur 2050 c'est C
c'est cette histoire de la grande
bascule des énergies fossiles vers
l'électricité alors au-delà des travaux
d'expertise technique et de modélisation
sur lesquel je reviendrai un petit peu
juste
après un élément crucial de la démarche
que nous avons mise en place c'est le
dispositif de concertation qui estta
assez inédit pour réaliser une telle
étude c'est important de consulter
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
intéressé pour avoir les scénarios les
analyses les plus les plus robustes et n
voyez ici quelques quelques chiffre de
de de ce dispositif on a mis en place
neuf groupes de travail technique avec
une quarantaine de réunions pendant
environ 2 ans avec 120 organisations qui
étaient représenté à la fois évidemment
des acteurs du secteur de l'énergie mais
aussi des ONG des des associations des
sy tank des acteurs académiques des
organisations syndicales et cetera
j'oublie probablement des des des
organisations mais vous voyez que
c'était assez varié on a essayé aussi de
tout au long de notre démarche de
documenter très précisément la méthode
les
hypothèses que que nous prévoyons
d'utiliser et on a appelé à des
contributions sur ces sujets là vous
voyez que on a fait une consultation
publique qui a reçu plus de 4000
réponses donc là on s'est étendu au-delà
des des acteurs traditionnel du secteur
énergétique c'est c'est une concultation
qui a intéressé beaucoup de monde y
compris parmi les citoyens
et en complément de ce travail de
concertation on a également mis en place
un Conseil scientifique
pluridisciplinaire que nous avons
sollicité pour apporter un avis sur
notre étude et nous avons également
développé plusieurs partenariats avec
des organismes institutionnels
académique spécialisés je peux citer par
exemple Météo France avec lequel nous
avons un partenariat stratégique et avec
qui nous avons étudier les conséquences
du réchauffement climatique sur le
système électrique on était parmi les
premiers en Europe à à faire ce type
d'étude euh parce que quand on regarde à
2050 bah le climat change et ça a aussi
des conséquences sur le système
électrique donc on a étudié ces aspects
là de très près je peux citer aussi par
exemple le partenariat que nous avions
avec le le BRGM pour étudier la question
de la criticité des ressources minérales
donc voilà c'est c'est des exemples et
j'insiste sur ce point de la
concertation et et et du travail avec
des organismes scientifiques parce que
ça a été un élément clé de notre
démarche de prospective euh nous le
reproduisons de manière systématique
hein désormais mais c'est ce qui
vraiment encore une fois permet de
consolider le travail de scénarisation
et d'identifier aussi des ruptures
possibles qu'on n'avait pas initialement
envisagé et que l'on peut ensuite
traiter sous la forme d'analyse de
sensibilité ou de stress test
euh quelques exemples là encore je vais
pas vous détailler tous nos scénarios en
fait il y en a il y en a beaucoup comme
vous pourrez le constater mais quelques
exemples des des questions que l'on
s'est posé pour faire ces projections
sur la consommation et la production
d'électricité alors de manière
schématique on a fait un travail d'un
côté sur vraiment la la question de la
consommation énergétique et notamment
électrique et et ce travaill il s'appuyé
sur différentes questions euh première
question c'est quel est le cadre
macro-économique dans lequel on se place
quelle est la politique industrielle par
rapport à laquelle on peut se placer à
des horizons de plusieurs décennies il y
a aussi des des questions sur
l'évolution et l'influence des habitudes
et des modes de vie on a beaucoup parlé
de sobriété ces derniers mois mais en
fait dans notre étude future énergétique
2050 avant même que le mot devienne à la
mode on avait tout un travail approfondi
sur la question de la sobriété
énergétique qu'est-ce que ça voulait
dire en terme de de de de d'habitude
dans dans l'habitat dans les
déplacements dans la façon de travailler
dans la façon de consommer et cetera
donc on a cétait un c'était un un
paramètre très important dans notre
travail c'est des questions vous le
voyez sur la performance des équipements
les équipements de demain consomment
moins d'énergie que ceux d'aujourd'hui
et cetera et donc sur la consommation on
avait cette modélisation technique
détaillée secteur par secteur usage par
usage avec différents trajectoire possi
he vous voyez qu'à la fin on a trois
scénarios principaux de consommation euh
donc ça ça permet de représenter
plusieurs futurs possibles et de manière
similaire sur la production on a essayé
d'étudier différents scénarios très
contrasté principalement sur la part des
énergies renouvelables et du nucléaire
donc on avait des scénarios qui se
prochetit sur une sortie du nucléaire à
l'horizon 2050 ou 2060 donc des
scénarios 100 % énergie renouvelable et
puis à l'inverse d'autres scénarios qui
étaient fondés qui s'appuyaient sur la
construction de nouveaux réacteur
nucléair et donc ensuite l'idée c'était
de pouvoir croiser toutes ces ces
projections voyez qu'à la fin ça fait 18
analyses croisées de scén ça fait
beaucoup mais ça permettait d'avoir
une une une diversité de futur possible
assez large et de pouvoir les comparer
sur la base de de de métriques
similaires enfin comparables les uns aux
autres donc pour finir sur la question
de l'analyse des scénarios parceune fois
qu'on avait construit des scénarios des
trajectoires possibles pour la
consommation et la production l'enjeu de
notre étude c'était aussi de pouvoir en
proposer une analyse détaillée
en quatre volets principaux technique
économique environnemental et sociétal
puisqueévidemment en fait les choix que
l'on fait sur le secteur énergétique ils
ont des impacts non seulement sur le
plan technique mais aussi sur le plan
économique sur le plan environnemental
et sociétal et ça a été un travail
important qui a été fait qui a mobilisé
des expertises différentes et vous voyez
ici quelques exemples he sur le volet
technique l'enjeu enfin les questions
c'était de savoir comment en 2050 en 60
on pouvait assurer le bon fonctionnement
du système électrique ça c'est quand
même la problématique qui nous intéresse
au premier plan euh pour nous
gestionnaires de réseau de transport
d'électricité mais il y a tout un
travail de de modélisation et de
simulation euh est-ce qu'on va avoir
assez d'électricité à tout instant pour
euh couvrir la consommation donc pour ça
on utilise des outils de modélisation
hein qui permettent de de simuler cet
équilibre heure par heure dans
différentes configurations
météorologiques qu'est-ce qui se passe
s'il fait froid chaud qu'est-ce qui se
passe s'il y a pas de vent et cetera on
l'a fait je l'ai dit sur différentes
trajectoires climatiques avec Météo
France ça c'était aussi un champ
important et puis on a regardé aussi les
impacts en terme de réseau à quel point
il fallait renforcer le réseau sur
quelle zone du territoire dans ce type
de scénario sur le plan économique la
question c'était celle évidemment du
coût du coût associé aux différents
choix possibles en intégrant l'ensemble
des composantes du système électrique
donc la production les moyens de
stockage de flexibilité et
l'infrastructure de
réseau c'était un volet qui était très
attendu et sur lequel on a on a attaché
une une attention particulière sur le
plan de la méthode et des hypothèses euh
c'est un un des volets qui étaient très
particulièrement concertés avec les
acteurs et sur lequel on a on a
sollicité l'AVE de de de de plusieurs
économistes pour pour consolider les les
les éléments de
méthode sur le plan environnemental on
avait des questions sur les impact
évidemment en matière d'émission de gaz
à effet de serre hein donc en matière de
réchauffement climatique mais aussi des
questions importantes sur sur
l'occupation des sols dans les
différents
scénarios sur le bilan en matière de
consommation de ressources par que la
question des la consommation des
ressources minérales critiques RAR et
cetera fait beaucoup débat dans cette
question de la transmission énergétique
on avait aussi des questions sur le
volume de déchets radioactifs dans les
différents scénarios ou encore sur le
volume de polluant atmosphérique donc
vous voyez là aussi différents impacts
qu'on a cherché à chiffrer à à évaluer
de manière quantitative pour objectiver
un peu les choix encore une fois je
reviens à l'objectif de départ éclairer
les choix de associer enfin éclairer les
les choix d'aujourd'hui associés au
secteur énergétique ça implique de bien
pouvoir quantifier un certain nombre
d'impact et sur le volet sociétal enfin
pour finir l'objectif c'était surtout de
documenter
explicitement les implications des
scénarios sur les modes de vie et les
conditions de réalisation de scénario
c'est quand on fait de la la
modélisation du secteur énergétique on a
tout un tas de paramètres par exemple
des paramètres sur le nombre de
kilomètres que vous allez parcourir
demain avec votre voiture et cetera le
nombre de de la surface des logements de
de demain donc tout ça c'est des petits
paramètres dans les modèles qui sont
parfois cachés hein dans les exercices
de prospective énergétique pour autant
ilells ont une implication très forte
sur les choix de société et donc c'est
ça qu'on a cherché à à à bien documenter
dans notre rapport pour pour que ça ça
ne reste pas des paramètres cachés
justement et j'insiste l'objectif
c'était pas de se dire qu'est-ce qui
était souhaitable qu'est-ce qui était
désirable du point de vue de la société
mais plutôt de bien décrire les
scénarios pour que après chacun puisse
faire des choix ou des propositions en
connaissant toutes les implications donc
toutes ces analyses on les a documenté
dans dans dans un dans un rapport dédié
qui est disponible pour tout le monde ça
fait un rapport volumineux mais je crois
que c'est quand même ce qui ce qui
permet de de de bien éclairer les les
choix publics sur le secteur énergétique
donc en en résumé hein pour finir euh je
pense que les points clés que je
pourrais citer sur notre approche hein
c'est d'abord partir d'un cadrage avec
un objectif précis là c'était l'objectif
de la sortie des énergies fossiles en
2050 deème point des hypothèses
documentées et concerté largement avec
différents types de parties prenantes
pour construire collectivement les
scénarios pour que ce soit pas juste un
travail de RTE mais un travail collectif
trème point des outils de modélisation
et de simulation éprouvé et à caractère
scientifique qui couvre différentes
expertises très variées le climat
l'environnement la modélisation
technique du système électrique et
cetera et enfin le 4è le 4e point dé
livrables qui permettent de documenter
qu'on a cherché aussi à à écrire de
manière pédagogique pour pour bien
mettre en évidence les les enjeux sur le
fonctionnement du système électrique à
long terme donc c'est tout ça que qu'on
essaie de mettre en place dans cette
approche de prospective à l'horizon 2050
et voilà j'en ai fini je laisse la
parole à à Monsieur
Colas merci beaucoup euh ministère des
armées est très sensible à à
l'invitation qui a pu être faite par la
Délégation à la prospective du Sénat euh
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
chers collègues euh l'expérimentation
RED team défense que dans je vais vous
dire quelques mots aujourd'hui s'est
terminé l'été dernier euh avec la
révélation de la la dernière saison des
travaux de l'arr team défense et l'idée
c'est de partager avec vous les les
résultats et puis l'expérience qui a été
vécue dans ce dans ce projet qui était
assez emblématique d'une capacité du
ministère des armées à savoir prendre
des risques euh et à faire preuve
d'audace dans un monde où justement on a
besoin euh de se mettre à penser
différemment face aux
incertitudes donc ce ce projet qui a été
bâti par l'agence de l'innovation de
défense euh a permis d'une part euh
d'avoir accès à différents canaux de
réflexion et je vais peut-être réussir à
à changer de slide euh oui c'est bon
j'ai réussi euh notamment par
l'impulsion de l'actuel délégé Générale
pour l'Armement Emmanuel Kiva qui à
l'époque était directeur de l'agence de
l'innovation de défense et qui avait
émis comme comme souhait de percer les
murs de l'imaginaire euh et donc lorsque
l'agence de l'innovation de défense en
2018 a été créée a émergé dès le départ
le besoin de de de créer un programme
qui permette euh de sortir du cadre euh
et de penser différemment et vous avez à
droite ce qu'on appelle le cône de
potentialité qui est un guide en terme
de méthodologie pour la RED team et qui
euh doit intégrer notamment euh on
parlait tout à l'heure de RTE avec les
le temps long et bien le ministère des
armées aussi c'est un un une entité qui
doit gérer le temps long et quand on
parle par exemple du porte-avion
nouvelle génération qui vara en 2040 et
bien ce type d'objet est extrêmement
intéressant à analyser d'un point de vue
de la RED team défense et de le faire on
va dire passer au tamis des risques et
des menaces
d'avenir également dans cette ambition
il y avait l'idée de ne pas partir seul
euh et de se tourner vers tout un
écosystème qui permettent de répondre
euh aux défis qui étaiit posés par ce
projet donc une direction de projet qui
a été placée au sein de l'agence de
l'innovation de défense et tout de suite
le choix de s'adosser à un acteur majeur
euh académique français qui était
l'Université Paris sciences et lettres
euh on en a parlé également tout à
l'heure euh en introduction euh la
démarche scientifique la démarche de
recherche était extrêmement importante
euh d'une part pour avoir des récits qui
soient le plus crédible possible et puis
également euh d'avoir euh desun matière
qui soit exploitable et qui on puisse
suivre dans la durée et donc ce projet
il a réuni euh avant tout une dizaine de
profils très créatifs puisque le
ministère des armées a fait le choix de
se tourner vers des auteurs et des
dessinateurs de scienceces-fiction qui
n'y connaissait strictement rien au
domaine militaire mais qui avait cette
capacité justement d'abstraction et
d'imaginer en dehors du cadre mais ces
auteurs évidemment n'ont pas travaillé
seuls et donc on a une centaines de
collaborateurs de personnes du ministère
des armées des ingénieurs des officiers
qui ont travaillé à leur côté pour
structurer ces scénarios de menace et on
verra tout à l'heure cette organisation
et puis comme je disais une démarche de
recherche donc une expertise
scientifique très forte fournie par
pariscien et lettres et donc c'est une
cinquantaine d'experts scientifiques à
chaque fois qui sont mobilisés sur les
différents travaux donc une un vrai
travail d'équipe et puis également de
manière à rendre le plus vivant possible
les scénarios et explo exploitable par
les différentes autorités du ministère
une dizaine d'équipes créatives pardon
que ce soit des équipes en terme de
studio de cinéma des dessinateurs des
designers on a également été travaillé
sur le côté de la représentation 3D et
puis tout ce qui est représentation
immersive donc il y a eu un vrai travail
de recherche dans la manière de
présenter l'ensemble des scénarios
produits ensuite une organisation qui
permettait justement un dialogue le plus
large possible entre différents acteurs
et donc la partie émergée de l'iceberg
que tout le monde connaît c'est l'arrê
team défense mais le vrai travail en
fait était effectué au sein du ministère
par la Blue team et cette blue team ce
sont ses officiers ce sont ses
ingénieurs de l'armement ce sont ces
experts de la Direction générale des
relations internationales de la
stratégie qui ont travaillé au côté de
la Blue team et c'est fondamental
aujourd'hui quand on travaille en tout
cas sur une sur une méthode de
prospective appliquée d'avoir l'ensemble
des acteurs à la manœuvre de la
transformation de l'entité impliqué dans
le projet de manière à ce que une fois
que les scénarios sont produits ils ne
restent pas hors sol mais il soit bien
intégré dans les travaux de réflexion de
l'entité qui les produit et puis vous
avez sur la droite les équipes qui ont
concouru à bâtir justement la
crédibilité des scénarios donc une
purple team qui elle était dédiée plutôt
à l'expertise et au renforcement de la
crédibilité des scénarios un exemple
assez concret par exemple quand nos
auteurs ont travaillé sur les pirates du
futur et on imaginer des villes
flottantes avec plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui vivaient dedans des
apatrides et bien ils se sont tournés
vers des experts pour dire comment
est-ce qu'on nourrit ces villes
flottantes la première la première
version des scénarios faisait apparaître
de la pisculture et en fait en
travaillant avec les experts il
s'avérrait que c'est pas du tout viable
pour nourrir plus de 2000 ou 3000
personnes parce que ça ne produit pas
assez donc ils ont été imaginés des bacs
dans lequel des bactéries produiser des
protéines alors c'est pas très
ragoutûtant je suis désolé pour cette
matinée mais voilà des exemples très
concrets et autre exemple sur
l'ascenseur spatial qui avait été évoqué
sur un des scénarios également bon ils
ils ont été cherchés des experts en
anocarbone et également des économistes
c'est important pour savoir combien
coûtait un ascenseur spatial demain je
vous donne le prix c'est 100 milliards
de d'euros
euh voilà vous avez également une black
team qui donc travaille sur toute la
partie euh organisation méthodologie
également production de euh de des
visuels et des vidéos et puis vous avez
une white qui était un comité qui devait
se charger notamment de considérer
l'indépendance totale de nos auteurs
puisque c'était ça aussi le postulat de
départ et cette prise de risque pour le
ministère des armées de laisser des gens
qui ne sont pas de l'entité réfléchir à
l'avenir et au problématique du
ministère des armées et ce comité devait
s'assurer justement de la parfaite
indépendance des auteurs et que le
ministère des armées ne venait pas
cadrer ou imposer des visions aux
auteurs également donc une démarche
expérimentale basé sur une méthodologie
qui a été bâtie pour le projet et donc
vous voyez alors différents niveaux de
travail qui qui sont réalisés au sein du
ministère des armées et avec les auteurs
et vous avez quatre grandes phases une
première phase qui va permettre d'ouvrir
les possibles puis de les refermer au
fur à mesure sur les différents canaux
d'intérêt pour le ministère donc c'est
la phase rouge et la phase bleue et bien
nos auteurs arrêtent de travailler ils
ne sont il ne savent même pas ce qu'on
fait avec scénario ça les frustre un
d'ailleurs mais derrière toute une phase
d'exploitation au sein de la Direction
générale de l'armement de l'état-major
des armées de la direction générale de
relations internationales et de la
stratégie et qui va justement permettre
d'irriguer de lancer peut-être des
projets ou de renforcer certaines études
ou certaines expérimentations en cours
le but étant pour pour ce programme de
bien incarner les menaces futures et les
rendre le plus tangible possible pour
les décideurs et ceux qui travaillent à
la préparation de l'avenir du
ministère également là vous avez une
planche qui a été réalisée par notre
ingénieur de recherche Marie rousi
encore une fois cette démarche elle se
veut extrêmement proche euh du domaine
de la recherche et universitaire et là
vous avez quelques exemples euh
aujourd'hui de Red teaming dans le monde
on voit que c'est essentiellement le
monde anglo-saxon qui travaille sur ces
sujets-là même si on a pu voir que
d'autres parties du monde également
avaient ce type d'initiative mais sur
lequel il communiquer moins et euh on va
dire que la différence euh avec certains
de nos alliés sur le programme français
d'une part c'est une approche euh de
science-fiction française c'est-à-dire
contrairement à la science-fiction
anglo-saxonne qui est technocentrée on
va prendre une technologie puis on va
l'étirer par exemple le quantique euh
l'intelligence artificielle le cyber
l'approche française est beaucoup plus
englobante notamment sur sa partie
sociétale euh et philosophique et c'est
extrêmement important aussi quand on
bâtit des menaces d'intégrer des faits
de société et d'intégrer évidemment
comment le monde de manière globale et
humaine évolue euh vis-à-vis de
certaines technologies et cette
approche-là est importante l'autre
différence avec les démarches étrangères
a été sa permanence puisque on a eu
quatre saisons qui ont été amené au sein
du ministère et donc cette continuité a
permis justement d'avoir une vision plus
globale et plus large de l'ensemble des
menaces
visées donc des réalisations qui ont été
égrainées au cours du temps sur sur
quatre quatre grands temps donc avec une
saison zéro une saison test hein qui
était un petit peu
là pour calibrer l'outil et puis ensuite
trois saisons correspondant à aux années
2021 2022 et 2023 en sachant qu'une
partie des des scénarios produits par la
RED team n'est pas publique et reste
classifié au sein du ministère donc les
les travaux que vous voyez ici sont ceux
qui ont été rendus public par le
ministre des Armées avec à chaque fois
voyez des des des des travaux qui sont
assez longs puisque c'est 9 mois de
travail pour produire un scénario avec
plusieurs ateliers de restitution et et
plusieurs dizaines d'ateliers de travail
à chaque fois donc c'est c'est une vraie
méthode qui s'inscrit dans le temps et
qui permet justement d'aller au fond de
la menace également une RED team défense
qui ne reste pas qu'à Paris c'est
important qui ne soit pas horors et donc
une RED team défense qui va dans tous
les sites du ministère des armées et
cette volonté d'habiliter nos auteurs au
niveau secret ce qui leur permet de
visiter des sites qui qu'il ne pourrai
pas visiter habituellement et donc de
s'imprégner aussi des difficultés et des
problématiques euh du ministère à avec
donc une production que vous voyez ici
avec différents sujets donc les premiers
sujets étaient sur la piraterie du futur
on a parlé également d'hypervélocité de
métaverse et donc de monde immersif on a
parlé de guerre écosystémique sur des
problématique notamment de
pollution des écosystèmes on a parlé de
crise énergétique avec après la nuit
carbonique et puis cette année on est on
s'est projeté dans l'espace avec la ruée
vers l'espace et on s'est projeté
également sur les capacité
d'apprentissage notamment via ce qu'on
appelle les les les les capteurs et les
implants neuronaux avec face à
l'dra donc un apport du programme assez
important pour pour le ministère des
armées à la fois pour susciter une
inspiration sur les menaces futures en
sachant que le programme RED team
défense n'est pas un programme qui vise
à analyser l'ensemble des menaces hein
c'est bien un programme complémentaire à
ce que fait le ministère des armées il
faut avoir des projets de prospective
beaucoup plus complets côté pour balayer
l'ensemble des menaces mais on va dire
que l'intérêt du programme RAM défense
c'est d'aller chercher justement des
signes noirs des des menaces queon
aurait pas voulu voir ou des tabou sur
lequels on ne voudrait pas travailler et
cet intérêt d'avoir des auteurs de
science-fiction c'est se décharger un
petit peu sur ces créatifs de
problématiques qui sont plus complexes à
traiter au sein du ministère des armées
et puis apporter un éclairage en rupture
vous parliez madêame la présidente
d'intelligence artificielle tout à
l'heure c'est très compliqué aujourd'hui
de se représenter les menaces
d'intelligence artificielle sur des
projets ou des produits qui sont assez
intangibles dans le monde du numérique
et justement Laar team défense permet de
se rendre compte ou de donner un cadre
visuel à ces menaces et donc de faire en
sorte que nos décideurs soi plus à
l'écoute et soit plus conscient de
certains dangers de certaines
problématiques et évidemment le sujet de
l'intelligence artificielle est au cœur
des enjeux et des sujets de travail du
du ministère des armées et le ministre
des Armées Sébas le Cornu est évidemment
très à l'écoute et et travaille sur
demande au ministère de travailler de
manière très important sur sur ce
sujet enfin encore une fois important
importance pour ce programme d'avoir une
cohérence et uneuité de la réflexion et
je le redis hein on connaît l'arr team
défense on connaît moins la la Blue team
donc les équipes qui travaillent au sein
du ministère et il est important pour
imaginer au-delà ce sont les mots de
Patrick aufor qui est le directeur de
l'agence de l'innovation de défense de
permettre une intég inration cohérente
des travaux de la RED team et c'est pour
ça qu'il y a un droit de de retour un
droit de visite un droit de suivi à
chaque fois sur ces scénarios de manière
à accompagner le mieux possible les
acteurs du ministère des armées que ce
soit à la DGA à l'état-major des armées
ou à la DG RS dans la construction des
solutions de demain à partir des
scénarios de la rtime voilà je vous
remercie pour votre
attention c'est nous qui vous remercions
tous les trois et j'ai le sentiment
après vous avoir écouté que tous vous
avez mis en avant d'avoir un fond qui
est très solide donc d'utiliser des
données des modèles qui ont déjà fait
leur preuve tout en y ajoutant une forme
là aussi très présente pour pouvoir
adresser le message au public et
finalement essayer d'emporter une
adhésion ou au moins pour que ça reste
pas que dans le monde de l'utopie mais
se dire demain c'est ça qui pourrait
arriver enfin moi c'est le un peu devis
essayer de retenir une idée qui englobe
vos vos trois vos trois Inter
intervention et une question que je me
posais aussi c'est donc quand vous
faites vos travaux de
prospective et quand vous avez précisé
que l'approche française est plus
englobante je me suis demandé si vous
vous posz enfin vous ne vous posez en
fait aucune limite mais il y a certaines
aujourd'hui nous on le voit enfin quand
on fait des travaux là du quotidien par
exemple lanil va nous empêcher de
pouvoir faire certains croisements de
fichier qui paraîtrait très intéressant
pour pouvoir répondre de manière précise
à un problème donc quand on tout ça à
échéance de 20 30 ans comment est-ce que
vous vous enfin comment est-ce que vous
prenez en compte en fait ce cadre
législatif réglementaire qu'il sera
nécessaire de faire évoluer sachant qu'
pour pouvoir le faire évoluer il faut
aussi d'un certain côté pouvoir emporter
l'adhésion des citoyens qui n'est pas
forcément chose facile sur ces questions
là ce que je vous propose c'est que s'il
y a d'autres questions les prennent
toutes parce que je sais que vous avez
pour certains des contraintes à
9h45 oui vas-y Bernard
oui une une question là je vois bien la
démarche ce que j'ai pas vu du tout
c'est est-ce qu'il y a eu des travaux
qui ont été faits par exemple comment on
voyait l'an 2000 en 1900 et finalement
quels ont été les biaiss comment à quel
endroit on s'est
trompé justement est-ce que ce ce
travail rétrospectif euh est intéressant
pour enrichir votre démarche
oui merci pour ces apports
je est-ce que dans la démarche de
prospective il y a des clauses de
revoyure est-ce et est-ce qu'il y a a
priori des méthodos
d'évaluation d'évaluation prospective
oui merci pour vos présentation
effectivement les les trois sujets sont
passionnants
euh je reviens juste sur celui de de RTE
euh effectivement
euh l'analyse par rapport à 20050 qui
est un objectif
fort vous avez pas évoqué le le prix
enfin la la notion de coût or entre 2010
et 2020 l'électricité a augmenté de 81 %
et et je dirais que les la part du
renouvelable notamment a été pour à peu
près 56 % de C et si ma question c'est
plutôt de dire sur cet objet là il y a
aussi un problème d'accèstit utilité
sociale je dis à dessin aujourd'hui le
1er février où l'électricité augmente de
10 % et je pense que ça c'est un peu
dans toutes les
têtes je je veux bien de peut-être
répondre aux premières question
euh peut-être réagir sur sur votre
commentaire général ou les points clés
que vous avez retenu je pense que c'est
effectivement les bons c'està dire que
si on a un travail de prospective
extrêmement rigoureux très sérieux mais
qui n'est lu par personne et qui n'a
aucune influence finalement il n'aura
servi à rien puisque l'objectif encore
une fois c'est pas de prévoir mais c'est
plutôt de pouvoir éclairer les décisions
donc savoir quels sont les processus qui
aujourd'hui permettent effectivement
d'impliquer les acteurs qui vont prendre
les décisions et aussi parfois déploie
les décisions qui sont prises ou les
mettent en œuvre ce qui est aussi
important est un point qui est très qui
est très très important vous avez tous
les deux insisté dans les exemples que
vous avez mentionné justement sur cette
partie qu'on appelle parfois
participation parfois concertation ation
et avec différents cercles d'acteurs qui
sont impliqués ça pour nous c'est
absolument essentiel on dit toujours en
prospective il faut penser pour réussir
une démarche de prospective il faut
penser à la fois les contenus et les
processus contenu processus en
permanence voilà
euh sur le la la question où c'eston
trompé et puis finalement si on fait une
rétrospective des travaux de prospective
est-ce qu'on est en capacité de de d'en
tirer un certain nombre de règles alors
c'est une question toujours assez
difficile évidemment on s'est toujours
trompé et puis on a toujours eu aussi un
petit peu raison quand on regarde les
travaux de d'anticipation qui était pas
forcément de la la prospective en tant
que telle des les plus anciens on
s'aperçoit alors notamment dans les
travaux aussi d'auteurs qui sont plutôt
de l'ordre de la science-fiction on
pense à Orwell on pense à d'autres on
s'aperçoit que souvent il y a des
capacités à anticiper effectivement des
grands domaines de changement à
percevoir là où les choses vont bouger
ce sur quoi on se trompe extrêmement
régulièrement c'est le rythme des
changements c'est final la plus grande
difficulté je trouve à intégrer dans nos
travaux de prospective c'est de bien
intégrer le rythme auquel les
changements vont arriver et évidemment
il y a aussi des tas de changement qu'on
ne voit pas voilà
euh on a toujours rêvé de taxi volant ou
de voiturees volantes voilà es sont
toujours pas là est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'elles n'arriveront jamais non pas
forcément mais quand je sais pas si RTE
s projeté là-dedans mais voilà l'armée
oui enfin les armées oui voilà mais donc
il il y a toujours cette question de des
horizons temporels qui en fait une
question vraiment très délicate et sur
certains sujets c'est c'est tout à fait
crucial ce que vous disiez sur le prix
de l'électricité on y reviendra tout à
l'heure c'est des choses qui font varier
considérablement les scénarios si jamais
tout à coup on a des chocs qu'on a pas
anticipé sur des questions sur des
questions de coût ou des innovations
technologiques les méthodes d'évaluation
et les clauses de revoyure je suis
rapide et puis je laisse mes mes
collègue complété il y a pas de méthode
d'évaluation standardisée sur les
travaux de prospective en revanche il
est effectivement extrêmement important
je pense quand on se lance dans un
travail de prospective que d'anticiper
au démarrage quels vont être les
critères sur lesquels on va évaluer la
la qualité du travail de prospective
est-ce qu'il faut attendre 2050 pour
juger des travaux de RTE je ne crois pas
euh je pense qu'il faut aussi voir
justement dans quelle mesure ils ont
aidé à prendre des décisions éclairées
et ça c'est à mon avis le premier
élément qui doit permettre justement de
conduire cette cette évaluation donc il
y a des évaluations sur la qualité et la
rigueur des travaux il y a des
évaluations aussi sur leur utilité et
donc le la capacité à les à les intégrer
dans les processus de décision mais bon
il y a pas de schéma complètement arrêté
c'est un chantier aujourd'hui sur la
prospective que de travailler davantage
sur les critères
d'évaluation pour répondre à à la
première question en effet sur comment
finalement dépasser le le mur
réglementaire et et parfois
administratif de de certains sujets
malgré l'envie de d'aller plus loin on a
évidemment au cœur de la direction
générement ces sujets là puisque
lorsqu'on doit faire voler un drone on
doit faire voler un avion on doit
travailler avec des explosifs il s'agit
pas de faire n'importe quoi et il s'agit
aussi pourtant de dépasser certaines
certains murs certains certaines
problématiques
technologique premièrement je pense que
des programmes de prospective peuvent
ramener une certaine vision et donner
une vision qui permet d'inspirer pas que
les ingénieurs pas que les officiers des
armées mais aussi la société toute
entière pour aller plus loin et pour
avoir envie de se dépasser et donc
donner un élan qui ne soit pas
uniquement au sein de l'institution
parce que aujourd'hui et on le voit on
parle beaucoup de simplification et on
voit que la simplification ça passe en
fait par un travail collaboratif avec
une multitude d'acteurs qui sont souvent
en dehors de l'organisation même qui
veut se simplifier donc redonner une
vision et inspirer la société toute
entière c'est aussi une démission de la
prospective de manière à pouvoir créer
des bulles d'expérimentation et c'est ça
aussi sur lequel la DGA travaille sur
comment se donner un un cadre qui va
être exceptionnel à un moment donné pour
pouvoir expéri enter quelque chose il
s'agit pas de tout casser il s'agit
juste de se dire donnons-nous la
possibilité de prendre un petit peu plus
de risque dans un secteur donné on fait
le test ça fonctionne ça ne fonctionne
pas si ça fonctionne allons un peu plus
loin donc cette stratégie de petit pas
elle est elle fait moins peur et elle
permet à des acteurs qui ont toute
prérogative pour faire en sorte que la
loi et les normes soit appliqué de
comprendre que là on s'en éloigne un
petit peu sous leur bienveillance et pas
dans un cadre global mais un pe peti à
une petite échelle et puis on va de
comme ça on évolue et ça permet
d'avancer en tout cas c'est l'approche
aujourd'hui qui qui qui est regarder sur
le rétro futur c'est extrêmement
important et extrêmement riche comme je
vous disais on travaill avec une
université qui a cette capacité d'avoir
justement une sorte de de regard avec
des archivistes paléographes qui vont
aller chercher aussi des des récits
anciens et puis faire une analyse et pas
que des récits occidentaux hein on peut
aller chercher des récits en Asie dans
le Caucase de voir comment les les
différentes différents pays pensent et
ont penser le futur c'est extrêmement
intéressant c'est l'objet je vous disais
que le programme RED team défense cétait
enfin l'expérimentation RED team défense
c'est terminé l'été dernier mais le
délégué général pour le moment a annoncé
qu'elle allait se poursuivre sous une
autre forme et dans cette autre forme on
a cette analyse et cette capacité
d'analyse de ce qui a pu être fait dans
le passé pour réinspirer et réalimenter
des scénarios futurs ensuite sur
l'évaluation de la
prospective nous ce qui nous intéresse
essentiellement avec le ce qui nous
intéressé essentiellement avec
l'expérimentation c'est de savoir se
poser les bonnes questions sur les
menaces d'avenir et donc au-delà même de
savoir est-ce que ça a produit quelque
chose est-ce que déjà le postulat de
départ c'est la la question de base a
été la bonne et cette question que
peut-être les gens ne voulaient pas voir
ou qu'ils ne voulaient pas se poser
est-ce qu'ils se la sont posé et donc ça
déjà en soit c'est une victoire et une
fois que cette bonne question est posée
et bien euh oui on a euh on a après un
un un indicateur pour savoir aussi
combien d'entités euh se sont emparé des
scénarios alors ils nous disent pas tout
le temps quand ils s'en empar
malheureusement euh c'est aussi ça la
liberté de la prospective et puis
l'autre point et et ça a été soulevé par
François Jouvenel c'est que souvent ce
qu'on imagine à 30 ans euh nous arrive
en à 6 mois et on l'a vu nous dans nos
scénarios euh un des exemples concrets
c'est euh quand n nos auteurs ont
travaillé sur les mondes persist les
mondes numériques persistants et sur les
métaverses 6 mois après le scénario
Facebook se transforma en méta bon voilà
donc ils avaient pas 10 ans d'avance ils
avaient juste 6 mois d'avance nos
auteurs donc ils étaient un petit peu
déçus mais ça voilà la réalité rattrape
très vite la fiction sur notamment sur
tous ces domaines technologiques voilà
je vous remercie je passe la parole à
Olivier
oui alors pour les différentes questions
si ouis si je reviens sur le le cas dans
lequel on se place pour faire nos nos
études c'était votre question madame la
Présidente
euh c'est vrai que quand on regarde à
des horizons de court terme on est
forcément dans un cadre de politique
donné de politique publique donnée et
donc ce que je disais au départ de mon
intervention quand on est sur quelques
années c'est plutôt ça relève plutôt de
la prévision on va pas révolutionner les
normes les règles à ces horizons là euh
donc on est vraiment sur du domaine de
la prévision à politique publique à
contexte donné en revanche quand on se
projette à l'horizon 2050
on on essaie de de s'écarter un petit
peu on sait queah pour atteindre
l'objectif de sortir des énergies
fossiles il faudra probablement changer
des choses en matière de de politique
publique enfin faire évoluer un certain
nombre de normes de de de de de
politique et et donc on essaie de de de
sortir un peu de du cadre existant pour
éclairer ces différents futurs possibles
euh alors peut-être la limite de notre
exercice c'est que on n'est pas allé
jusqu'à dire exactement quel seraient
les évolutions
législative ou de politique publique
qu'il faudrait dans chacun des scénarios
mais en tout cas on essaie de de décrire
ces futurs possibles un bon exemple
c'est celui de la sobriété on sait que
quand on parle de de sobriété c'est pas
juste dans nos scénarios du changement
de comportement on est un l'eau quand on
se brosse les dents et cetera c'est
aussi des vrais changements de société
des vrais changement d'organisation de
la société qui passent probablement par
des évolutions de politique publique
assez fortes assez structurantes donc
voilà quand on fait nos scénarios on
essaie vraiment de sortir du cadre et
c'est en ça que les l'exercice de
concertation j' reviens souvent mais
l'exercice de concertation de de de
prise en compte d'autres d'autres avis
il est important parce que on a envie de
sortir du cadre mais il faut aussi
savoir qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu' est
réaliste quand même de de de de
d'imaginer à ces horizons sur la
question de de la rétrospective c'est
vrai que dans le secteur énergétique on
a la chance d'avoir eu
des des des des des prédécesseurs qui
ont très largement travaillé sur C
question dans les années 70- 80 avec le
Commissariat général au Plan notamment
et puis la la le lancement du programme
électronucléaire en France donc on a
quelques données ce qu'on ce qu'on peut
constater enfin des choses effectivement
qu'on qu'on retrouve c'est que forcément
bah on sait enfin je dis on ou en tout
cas les les les personnes les les les
études de l'époque se sont forcément
trompé ou n'ont pas prédit tout ce qui
allait se passer par exemple sur la
consommation d'électricité historique
quement les trajectoires étaient très
hautes par rapport à ce qu'on a vu en
réalité pour autant est-ce qu'on a
forcément pris des mauvaises décisions
sur la base de ces études c'est pas sûr
il y a aussi probablement des des choses
qui nous a permis d'avoir un système
énergétique qui est aujourd'hui assez
robuste donc je pense que c'est ce que
disait aussi François de Jouvenel quand
on fait nos nos études à long terme il
faut être modeste on n pas de boule de
cristal on n'est pas là pour prédire le
futur mais par contre on est là pour
essayer d'éclairer les décisions et
peut-être que même si on n pas prévu
exactement ce qui allait se passer les
les les décisions qu'on qu'on va pouvoir
mettre en œuvre c'est celle qui étaai
les les plus les plus robustes au moment
donné où on les a prises et c'est en ça
aussi que l'exercice que l'on fait de
d'approche multicénario d'avoir beaucoup
d'analyse de sensibilité c'est important
parce que ça permet d'anticiper aussi la
robustesse des choix c'est vraiment ça
qu'on essaie de faire c'est d'avoir
cette robustesse de regarder beaucoup de
sensibilité qu'est-ce qui se passe si
jamais les modes de vie évoluent de
telle manière qu'est-ce qui se passe si
le climat évolue de telle manière alors
on peut pousser effectivement l'exercice
plus loin je pense que moi je suis
fasciné par ce qui a été fait par la RED
team défense
euh et et c'est aussi des choses qu'on
auquel on essaie de réfléchir comment on
donne plus de résilience au système en
regardant des scénarios de vraies
rupture en sortant encore plus du cadre
ça demande un petit peu de de temps pour
y réfléchir posément mais c'est c'est
cette question de la résilience elle est
de plus en plus prégnante dans le dans
dans le secteur énergétique
euh sur la question des causes de
revoyure bah oui effectivement nos
études elles sont actualisées presque en
permanence hein j'en parlais avec
François de jouenel juste avant cette
cette cette audition euh quasiment tous
les 2 ans on remet à jour no nos
perspectives il y a des choses qu'on
avait plus plus ou moins bien prévu et
donc on réactualise là par exemple
depuis qu'on a publié les futurs
énergétiques 2050 on a réactualisé le le
le début de période jusqu'à 2035 et on
voit qu'il y a un certain nombre de
changements qui pourrait intervenir
encore plus vite que ce qu'on avait
imaginé il y a encore quelques
années et enfin sur la question plus
spécifique des des prix et coûts de
l'énergie ça fait bien partie en fait
c'est un volet très important à notre
analyse d'essayer de bien chiffrer le
coût du système électrique à long terme
dans les différents scénarios en
prendant toutes les composantes de coup
parce que bon souvent vous avez euh des
des des des Institut des organismes qui
comparent juste le coût des énergies
renouvelables ou le coût du nucléaire n
ce qu'on a cherché à faire c'est bien
prendre en compte l'ensemble des cou en
intégrant le les systèmes de stockage
qui étaient nécessairire le réseaux donc
on a vraiment fait une évaluation
économique complète après la comparaison
avec les prix l'électricité elle est
elle est forcément plus compliquée puce
que les prix ça relève aujourd'hui
plutôt de logique de d'une approche de
court terme il dépendent beaucoup de
paramètres de court terme sur le prix du
gaz l'évolution de la consommation à
court terme l'évolution de la production
à court terme quand on regarde quand on
se projette sur des horizons plus
lointains on a une réflexion qui est
plutôt
une approche long terme on regarde
l'amortissement des coûts des coûts
d'investissement sur des temps très
longs c'est c'est c'est c'est vraiment
cet indicateur là cet indicateur
économique qui nous a paru le plus
pertinent pour éclairer les les
décisions publiques mais je pense que
tout est quand même vraiment chiffré
dans notre dans notre
rapport merci vraiment à tous les trois
et en allant là regarder la page de la
RED team défense en fait je je viens de
voir que vous avez fait des travaux qui
sont complètement en phase avec des
travaux de la délégation il y a quelques
mois non mais oui parce que donc en fait
la délégation poursuit pour mes
collègues c'est les travaux sur l'espace
et on est en train de poursuivre pour
essayer d'avoir une traduction
législative de ce qu'on avait identifié
et donc je vois que vous avez fait tout
un scénario qui est exactement sur notre
sujet des ressources donc voilà ça aa
été ma mon ultime question est-ce que
vous notez sur des coins de papier quand
vous faites vos scénarios de prospective
ce qu'il faudrait vraiment changer dans
la loi pour que les choses puissent
advenir ou que moins la France puisse
préparer aux menaces qu'elle rencontre
alors dans le domaine de la défense on
la voit bien mais dans le domaine de
l'énergie c'est la même chose et là par
exemple quand vous parliez des questions
d'amortissement des investissements ça
pose plein de choses sur les réseaux sur
la tarification qu'on en fait donc
est-ce que voilà au moment où vous
écrivez vous vous dites bon bah voilà il
y a tout ça là aujourd'hui le cadre
actuel il ne marche pas euh mais il
faudra qu'un jour on on a prendre notre
bâton pour aller parler au au
parlementairire ou à l'exécutif pour
faire changer les choses
merci pour votre question madame la
Présidente alors le programme RED team
défense est pour l'instant au service du
ministère des armées donc évidemment il
a pas il a pas encore fait cette
démarche exhaustive d'aller d'aller
d'aller trouver dans dans la loi ou dans
dans les projets de loi des voies
d'inflexion par rapport au scénario par
contre ce qui a pu être fait notamment
dans la préparation la loi de
programmation militaire et ce qui a pu
être fait également dans les différentes
normes je parlais tout à l'heure des
drones ou de tout ce qui est
réglementaire au niveau robot tique il y
a des travaux qui ont été faits pour se
dire et là c'est encore une fois non pas
la RED team qui l'a fait mais la Blue
team d'aller chercher au sein du
ministère les textes réglementaires qui
devraient évoluer demain et comment on
illustre ce changement par les scénarios
de la réam et c'est là où on revient au
pouvoir fondamental de la prospective de
changer les esprits et de donner une
vision et un pouvoir de changement et
d'entraînement et une force
d'entraînement et donc par contre nous
on est très heureux au ministère des
armées quand des scénarios de l'AR team
peuvent servir à d'autres entités pour
appu
leur démarche de transformation de
changement et de redonner une vision
donc on est on est tout à fait out à
vous partager nos scénarios pour vos
travaux évidemment ce sera avec grande
joie il ne reste plus qu'à vous
remercier tous les trois de nous avoir
éclairé et d'éclairer tous ceux qui
regarderont ensuite la vidéo en ligne
prochainement et donc bah des
collaborations futur puisque pour
certains vous êtes des interlocuteurs
quand même assez réguliers du
Sénat bonne